the overall theme of the film I got from
anyway was about a young girl you know
trying to find her purse and trying to
figure out what she wants to do in life
yeah and which is kind of what we all go
through right so it's really relatable
like especially when I was watching that
have you ever been in a point like that
yourself what have you always known what
you want to do totally not that's what
that's why I kind of relate and I think
most people do yeah you know when I was
probably run she's 20 when we meet her
in the film yeah and that was probably
during the time when I I was working in
a Levi's store I'd quit ballet school
which I thought was my gonna be my path
but I my my gut instinct told me that I
want to do something different I had
tried out for theater school and I
didn't come in and I just remember I
remember cuz I met I still kind of have
the same close friends that I've met
when I was like 18 17 and we we set now
because now we're getting closer to 30
and I'm like do you remember where we
just wanted to fast-forward cuz I just
wanted to it was like so what is gonna
you know I just didn't know yeah it was
gonna happen and but that is also part
of I think a very important time when
you you also get to try different things
and I think like Lauren this film you
shouldn't feel pressured a lot of people
around her telling her you should step
into you you know the shoes are your dad
you should follow his path that she you
know she says no I'm not gonna I mean
and she has a manner and all the riches
in the world but she wants to really you
know do her own thing and and and and
find her own footing and find her own
path you obviously had to do a lot of
physical training I can imagine for this
film yeah she looked amazing
could you talk me through like you what
was your routine like in the gym and how
often did she mean well yeah I mean it
was so many different skills of course
that I practiced with this role but I
also to be able to gain I gained about
10 12 pounds of muscle and I had a
magnet my trainer who I worked with for
four months leading up to it and that
and then every day before I started to
film I was in the gym and something that
I learned was you know I've done much
more kind of yoga and Pilates and a lot
of cardio but
I started to integrate a lot more muscle
training a lot more and that is still do
none of the same level I did film but
that was something that I really enjoyed
I felt very much in my body and I loved
having another kind of strength
yeah and how often did you train every
day it's five to six days a week
pretty much yeah and yeah and then
Sunday's was pizza day pizza day oh yeah
you're waiting no I think the first
thing I said was do you have any like
quirky health or bonus tips that you did
during training um or just in general I
yeah it's one of those things a nose
when I travel a lot like sleep oh my god
it changes the way you look the way you
feel and and and the way you know how
you just feel generally in life at the
moment you know so that's something that
I know myself I'm like my mom used to
tell me when I was kid and when she said
I had to go to bed at 7:30
I said why she was like well cuz you do
get a bit grumpy when you don't 14 and I
realized when I'm old I was like that is
actually true yeah speaking of like
looking like beauty and you know bonus
you also doing lots of travel yeah do
you have any like products and skincare
because I mean of course now I have a
wonderful professional team this make me
look you know put on my makeover camera
and things but I very rarely use makeup
in my everyday life but I I love
skincare and if anything my my skin goes
extremely dry so you will find me I can
put like hand cream in my face
this delfano goes in so on flights and
things I always put on like masks or I
have I always have a night cream as my
day cream oh yeah